ce que vous voyez à l'écran ça va vous
faire sourire quand vous allez
comprendre exactement c'est quoi c'est
pas de mise en scène sont des rats qui
conduisent des voitures des petites
voitures
il peut se passer pas mal de choses
bizarres dans les laboratoires
scientifiques et renault bonjour le
terrorisme alors le but c'était quoi en
faisant conduire à ce qu'ils ont réussi
c'est certain c'est d'attendrir tout le
monde le suspense était une vidéo qui
est extrêmement populaire sur internet
cette semaine mais c'est pas juste un
vidéo virale qu'ils ont voulu faire ils
vivront une expérience sérieuse derrière
tout ça c'est une expérience sur le
cerveau en fait que de ces animaux-là
bon à la base ce qu'on voit c'est
l'écran les lire on appris à conduire
ces petites voitures l'os ce n'est pas
très compliqué l'idée des fils de cuivre
à l'intérieur dépendamment du oui
mettent leurs pattes ça tourne à gauche
à droite ouais ils vont tout droit et là
ils s'en sont servis pour atteindre des
franques loppsi dont les petites sirènes
sucrées qui était dans un coin leur
enclos qui pouvait juste atteindre 6 il
utilisait la voiture mais là ce que les
chercheurs c'est donc ce c'est assez
sympa la base mais ce qui est vraiment
intéressant ici c'est là que
l'expérience commence c'est que les
chercheurs ont remarqué que c'est pas
tout l'erreur qu'ils étaient capables
d'apprendre à facilement conduire leurs
petites voitures ces jeux sur qui avait
grandi qui avaient passé leur vie dans
un environnement qu'on dit stimulant
donc sur un environnement où il y avait
toujours des nouveaux objets des choses
pour pour les mettre au défi des petits
pas au des trucs des jo des choses qui
faisaient qu'ils apprennent un peu à
tous les jours oui on a pris facilement
les cerveaux avait été assistés c'est
exactement ce alors que d'autres animaux
qui avait grandi dans un environnement
post stimulant mais eux ils ont jamais
été intéressé par la voiture ils ont pas
réussi à attraper le petit peloton loops
ce que les chercheurs ont montré
d'intéressant aussi c'est que les
animaux quiconque y apprenait facilement
était aussi mon extrait sic
donc il y avait moins d'hormones de
stress dans leur sens que ceux qui
avaient de la difficulté donc ça ce que
je sais que les lilin le fait qu on
stimule à stimuler notre cerveau tout le
temps ça aide à apprendre c'était
quelque chose dont je doute est déjà un
moment mais ceci est un modèle animal
c'est la première fois qu'on réussit à
le montrer ailleurs est ce ça va pouvoir
être utile chez l'humain donc on peut se
servir de ce modèle là pour comprendre
un peu le cerveau du rock lancé le
compare à l'humain pour voir comment
l'humain chez l'humain par exemple la
motivation fonctionne comme à
l'apprentissage fonctionne et quand il
ya des problèmes la dent mais comment ça
peut venir du stress et peut-être même
en la dépression donc c'est selon
les parallèles expérience amusante mais
fort intéressant les résultats qu'on va
aller chercher maintenant et s'est passé
des choses encore plus sérieuse semaine
sur la planète science si on peut dire l
oms l'organisation mondiale de la santé
qui a mentionné que la polio à l'aide
chose du passé d'ici peu
oui ça c'est vrai que ce soit sur une
nouvelle importante pour ce qui est de
la lutte contre la poliomyélite qui est
arrivé cette semaine c'est l'om est ce
qu a annoncé qu'il avait complètement
éradiqué une des trois formes du virus
c'est ça c'est le risque
un résultat qui arrive après des
décennies de vaccination il faut se
rappeler le sort monde aujourd'hui la
poliomyélite on n'en parle plus beaucoup
mais autrefois dans les années 50 la
folie est une maladie infantile
extrêmement parmi les plus terribles qui
existait ça visait surtout les enfants
en des fois même en bas âge jusqu'à 5
ans et moins et ça ça attaque et les
neurones moteurs chez ces enfants là
donc c'est les neurones qui nous
permettent de bouger nos muscles tout de
même de respirer et dont il y avait un
demi million d'enfants qui mouraient
dans les années cinquante à chaque année
de cette maladie dans le monde et les
survivants brise était comment le voyez
à l'écran quelques instants le cti êtes
il avait déjà été paralysé il avait des
difficultés de se mouvoir il ya des
malformations niveau leurs jambes en
amérique va même se retrouver sous
respirateur artificiel dans les années
80 on avait on avait quand même réussi à
baisser les coûts grâce à la vaccination
mais restait quand même 120 pays dans le
monde où ce virus-là existait toujours
donc l'om et se lancer une grande
campagne de vaccination et on est passé
de 350 mille cas chaque année dans les
années 80 a seulement 94 cas cette année
en 2019
donc c'était un immense succès qui est
arrivé grâce justement à la vaccination
il en reste encore dans quelles régions
du globe on sait pour l'instant si on
devient de plus beaucoup fort appui à
trois versions de ce virus là le type 2
était complètement éliminés en 2014
le titre iii qui est éliminée cette
semaine les derniers cost en 2016 au
nigeria le pays qu'on voit en bleu sur
l'écran ce moment et maintenant il reste
le type 1 qui existent en afghanistan et
au pakistan
ce serait un peu difficile de faire la
campagne de vaccination là bas parce que
les conditions sur le terrain sont assez
difficile surtout dans les maisons qui
sont encore les zones de guerre mais si
tout fonctionne bien on peut les
chercheurs sur b les médecins sont
convaincus qu'ils pourraient éliminer
complètement la polio d'ici 2023 et si
on y arrive ce serait la deuxième fois
dans l'histoire qu'on élimine une
maladie après la variole
ce serait un énorme succès vraiment pour
la vexer oui ce serait un succès
scientifiques
ça a sauvé vraiment beaucoup de vies ce
toute cette vague là et là je sais que
pour finir vous voulez nous montrer une
image qui veulent louer penser à
l'halloween un masque dans ce qu'on voit
à l'écran en ce moment c'est cet animal
a bossé sur le mot si cet animal
apparaîtrait c'est ça cognait ma fenêtre
je pense que je serai le seul ordre une
chauve souris avec auquel on a greffé
des petites araignées sur ses mains ça
s'anime à la cfl aïe aïe
donc on le voit c'est un primate la
famille des les mains on retrouve
seulement à madagascar
mais si haut si particulier parce que
c'est le seul primate du monde à avoir
si doit donc sévi sur un animal nocturne
mais ce qui paraît si particulier avec
lui c'est qu'un index très long qu'on
peut voir l'écran ce moment et sans ça
pour taper sur les troncs d'arbres et
repérer les insectes dont six tours il
un peu comme à paris co localisation
comme avec comme les chauves souris donc
ses yeux plein d'étudiants une étude qui
est paru cette semaine sur cet animal
ajustements mais on n'a pas besoin de ça
pour en parler c'est un animal qui est
assez fascinant et ça fait bien avec
l'halloween je pense day1a si bon animal
de compagnie à voir dans la rue vous
avez validé à mes enfants donnez pas
l'idée paraissait chercheurs mais j'ai
intéresser d'autres